>>You hear about data-driven
schools all the time,
but we are truly data-driven.
Sharing the data the
way we do at our school,
I think it's super important.
Because once you have
everybody working together,
you have the teachers, you
have the interventionists,
you have the aides and now
you've got the parents on board,
you can't have anything
but success.
In the last five years,
we started really sending
home data with explanations.
When I send the data home then
parents will start calling.
I leave my first half hour
of the day free so that
if I have phone calls or if
they are dropping their kids off
and have a question,
they can come down here.
They know I'm open.
We have a parent data night
at the beginning of
every school year.
We try to have it after
work hours and I get
up on the overhead and I
explain what the data is,
what it looks like, what we
do, what we're looking for
and what they can
do at home to help.
I make a folder on every
single student that I see.
It shows every single test that
we did, every single indicator
that we did and where they
fell in each individual test.
It also gives them a cheat
sheet on the acronyms,
because teachers have a
tendency to talk in acronyms
and talk in teacher-ese.
So if it says "oral
reading fluency,"
I give them a cheat
sheet that says,
that is how many words
you read a minute.
They do get a standard
report card too,
but sometimes it's like,
"I got a B in reading.
What does that mean?
My kid can read."
>>Maureen: So when
Tony came in August,
this is an average C
student in the green.
This is a below average
student in the yellow.
And this is well below
average in the red.
If he follows this path, which
is what we're expecting him
to do, then he will
be an average student
in second grade by May.
The first test that we gave him
is the nonsense words fluency
correct letter sounds.
These are your nonsense words.
Now they look kind of odd for
adults, but if you think of them
as like syllables, like
"re" is a nonsense word,
"peat" is a nonsense word, but
together they're a word, repeat.
So at the beginning of the
year when we tested him,
he read thirty-one sounds.
But now that we've been
working with him for six weeks,
he's up to seventy sounds.
>>Mom: Great.
>>Maureen: I know.
And if you're going to
work with him at home,
really encourage him to
read them as whole words.
>>Nine out of ten parents
say, "What can I do to help?"
And if you just say, "Read
with them," well, read what?
Getting down to specific
skill gives the parents some
empowerment to do something
about getting that grade better.
>>Felicia: I think definitely
it's made me more engaged.
I know what to work
on with Brayden,
so I pay attention more.
We've practiced a
lot with reading.Z
>>Brayden: She helps
me read a lot,
helps me get the harder
books and harder chapters.
>>Maureen: Everyone wants their
kids to do well, so they want
to know exactly where they are
and how we're going
to get better.
>>Carla: Jose was way behind.
It started in kindergarten all
the way through second grade,
he was below grade
level, and he started
at Humboldt his third
grade year.
>>Maureen: He was well,
well below average.
He had no confidence
and he said,
"I can't read" and
"I don't read."
His parents were
kind of defeated
because he'd been getting
bad grades where he was,
and mom got a data report.
>>Carla: She handed me the
folder and I opened it up
and I was just in awe
and shock and tears,
because I could see right
away the growth on the chart
where he was way down,
and he was way high now.
>>Maureen: And he ended
up staying in Title I
because he had a tendency to
go up and down, up and down.
But to see that he
was making progress,
it motivated him,
it motivated her.
>>Jose: She pressed her left
hand to her cheek and smiled.
>>Carla: I could
see the progress
and I could see his achievements
and I felt like what I was doing
at home was helping with what
they were doing at school.
>>Jose: I read a lot.
I read about bats.
I read about animals.
I learn lots of things
and my grades go higher
and higher and higher.
>>Carla: He went from not
wanting to read to, "Look Mom,
I got a chapter book, and
this book's about the--
can I read this to you?"
And I'm like, "Of course."
I believe if you have
communication between teachers,
parents, staff, that
parents feel comfortable,
kids feel comfortable
and I think it's valuable
that they communicate with
you because then you know
where your child's at.
>>Maureen: The fact that we all
work together as one big group,
I think a lot of our success is
part of that, and the success
that we've had as
a school tells us
that we're doing
the right thing.